you can do what I did which was very
labor-intensive and very effective but
it takes a lot of time and that's called
copy work and so what I did was I got
ahold of the hundred best sales letters
of all time
I don't know what makes it 100 best but
it's just famous sales letters so and
then in the 50s 60s 70s 80s and 90s
before the internet really came around
and it even happened after that but
predominantly before that these salesmen
would send these letters to people's
homes and they would try to convince
people to get interested in buying a
vacuum or an encyclopedia or a pair of
sunglasses and the it was typically the
they were typically wrote the wives the
the housewife would take out her
checkbook and be like oh this is really
interesting I need to buy this and she
would write a check put it into the
envelope and sale it back that's a lot
of friction and so these people were so
good at using words because it was so
expensive to sell all these letters I
had to be good they were so good at
using their words that they had to that
they convince these strangers to write a
check and mail to him and so I found
these hundred letters and if you google
best sales letters of all time you're
gonna find them and I would I spent
probably six months where I would spend
about two or three hours a day and when
I was 22 years old I would write them
all out by hand I would also do that
with books oh the Great Gatsby Saturday
Night Live live scripts I would do it
with movie scripts just any piece of
great writing I would do that with and
when you do this it's kind of like how
you learn an instrument the way that we
teach people how to play music it's
incredibly effective so if I hand you a
guitar or a piano I don't say go ahead
write a song I tell you copy the
star-spangled banner' go play jingle
bells go look at Jimi Hendrix go look at
Led Zeppelin play all this all these
copy all these other people steal their
work for a little while and or whatever
genre you're interested go and copy them
exactly and in time you're gonna learn
how to feel the texture you're gonna see
the patterns that work best that works
extremely well with writing and it's the
same concept I call
coppy work this is how a lot of people
used to learn our school our schooling
the way that we do it now it's changed
over the last handful of decades but for
a long time people used to do this Ben
Franklin was a great writer and he said
this is how he learned how to write and
its really effective so it's called copy
work the second thing that you can do
and I'm biased
Neville is my good friend but there's a
guy named Neville Medora and I actually
met him because I bought his course and
I bought his course and then after I
took his course I became friends with
them and years later we became best
friends and he was the best man at my
wedding so I love Neville and so I'm
biased but his course is what I took to
learn about copyrighting he's he's got
this course called copywriting course
it's spelled with AK a copy with a k'
and course with a k' I don't know it's
always stands out it's a great course I
don't know how much it cost right now it
could cost a few hundred bucks or a
hundred I don't even know but it's
relatively affordable and I think if you
don't like it he'll refund you his money
your money but anyway it's a great
course so it teaches a lot of this stuff
it's worth it it's totally worth it and
I actually think I used to promote this
so much that if you go to copywriting
course comm slash Sam I've got like a
referral link and I think there's like a
$50 off code or something you could use
so if that interests you do that the
third thing is this book called
advertising secrets of the written word
by Jo Sugarman it's a great book it
costs $10 and I bet you if you google
google it correctly you can find a free
PDF of it online it's a great book that
walks you through copywriting principles
and why certain things work and why they
don't and finally the last thing it's
not a copywriting thing but it's a
writing thing and it's a book by Stephen
King called on writing and the first
half of the book is it's it reads really
fast it's only 250 pages maybe the first
half it's all about his tools and tricks
and his toolbox he calls it his tool kit
or his toolbox for writing well and it's
incredibly effective it's it he has got
rules like don't use too many adverbs or
keep your sentences short things like
that it's incredibly effective it's a
great book on writing the second half of
the book is about his biography and it's
really really fascinating so it's called
on running by Stephen King so a second
skill set that I wanted to go through
copywriting I think that because I know
how I would say I'm a pretty good
copywriter I'm a B because I am a B
copywriter until the day I die I will
never be homeless I will always make
money now verdicts still out if I'm
gonna be very very wealthy but I will
bet everything which I am betting
everything by starting businesses and
things like that that no matter what
happens I will always be able to make a
really good salary rather as an employee
or selling someone else's products so I
think that copywriting is incredibly
effective it's it's just it's really
useful for your life business and just
living
[Music]